sheep impress vests outside the offices
of Novaya Gazeta in Moscow the display
might look cute but it's no petting zoo
instead it's part of the latest scare
campaign against the opposition
newspaper just a few days before the
journalists received a severed sheep's
head and a funeral wreath addressed to
the editor-in-chief and to journalist
denis karat cough cough cough has worked
for Novaya Gazeta from saint-petersburg
since september even in this cafe in the
centre of the city he worries about
surveillance on the internet he's been
accused of being a traitor the wave of
online hate is connected to his
investigation into the dealings of
Putin's cohort Evgeny precaution he's
allegedly behind the so-called troll
Factory which pays people to promote the
Kremlin's interests online and behind a
controversial Russian mercenary group
addresses on the internet information
about my relatives members of my family
they openly discuss online about what to
do to me pleasant and enjoyable of
course I don't but do I feel a certain
satisfaction because these threats mean
that I wrote the right thing yes Kurata
coughs colleagues in Moscow at their
daily planning conference the newspaper
is one of the last truly critical media
outlets in Russia for over 25 years
Novaya Gazeta has been highly regarded
for its investigative articles into
corruption and human rights abuses for
years now the journalists here have felt
the restrictions on press freedom in the
country tighten six of the papers
journalists have paid for their
reporting with their lives including on
the parade Kafka she was murdered in
2006 political ska was known for her
critical reporting about the conflict in
Chechnya an element of fear has become
part of everyday life at Novaya Gazeta
our newspaper has lost as many
journalists as if we were reporting
during wartime
even though Russia is not at war it's
like working in a minefield if you had
to choose whether they should send a
sheep's head or come without warning and
murder someone then I'd rather have a
severed sheep's head every single day
the head of the Russian journalists
union on the other hand says the bigger
picture when it comes to press freedom
and Russia is positive I think in Russia
both journalists and the government is
still learning how to communicate with
each other and even though there are
problems there is overage there are
violations that verge on censorship
nevertheless the situation overall is
improving and internationally speaking
the situation in Russia is decent but -
Denis Karabakh off his work certainly
feels dangerous he sees the risk as a
given a normal part of his investigative
reporting that he's willing to accept
though it has meant that even his
daughter has been threatened I'm
interested in uncovering stories that
you can't see with the naked eye things
that aren't right and the surface
dealings that are secret are usually
criminal dealings of course when you do
this work you can take on heirs of
nothing can stop me but of course I have
my limits and God forbid if my opponents
ever sound out what those limits are cut
off won't say what story he's currently
working on for Novaya Gazeta but he's
sure of one thing he'll have to be ready
to face more threats